but he's not funny than I've actually
been there was some discussion does he
look decent yesterday I was asked what I
thought I said now it's Moody a blocked
away easily man cousins gets the block
Denver keeps the basketball to six
Denver
it's got to be about counting points in
the paint it's got to be my cousins so
free gets the foul I'll use it down
that's a great entry obviously Rondo
trying to settle everything down eat
check for Emmanuel mudiay it'll be Rondo
he talked he took five with him those
guys are okay the rebound but this is a
pass all the way and that's well done
Holliday one right pop art instead
cousins all the way the whole content
stop this freight ring that's not fair
cousins over on for read on the speed
the three-point play everything came out
of the bag of tricks that time big bands
come on stop stop that you guys gonna do
all that at that size and he gave him
everything in and out cross he finished
the season he had a twenty seven point
game he had a better 30 point game his
costumes going hard
cutter reaches by 4e then let go they're
off to a good start here in the third
quarter 7o push some one more and about
the passing cousins on the fly by now
you got to go more jackpot hands he
knows how to pick it up because you
gotta maximize what you do with those
two out there perfect has put the over
the shoulder stays with the play and
cousins on 26 sideline as soon as
possible
inside position Marie the longer one
cousins second chance points yes way
it'll be Darius Miller checking in for
the palace it's fun to play and the gods
s dozens write Bible read again turn
down a ton any other night just bomba no
I added to your point there's nothing
click that yes in this release is much
better better deep for a guy take a
slave and I for the Powell's and the
pelicans starting to create a little bit
as dozens upon more good setup and
bubble expected contact can he didn't
get
interesting a 17-point game and nobody
there to protect plumpy but he did a
better job that time out of the RT
Claude more not surprised